vincent nous aurions tant voulu te
sauver de la barbarie à cette soirée de
recueillement
ils sont tous venus défendre vincent
lambert
on n'a pas le droit des talents une
petite flamme si petite soit elle on a
aboli la peine de mort pour les pour les
pour les coupables on la maintient pour
pour des innocents et vincent lambert
est un hymne au son de la colère pour le
sort réservé à cet homme victime d'un
accident de voiture en 2008 devenue
tétraplégique
il était maintenu dans un état végétatif
depuis près de 11 ans jusqu'à ce matin
il est mort ici
les médecins ont arrêté de le nourrir la
semaine dernière c'est un soulagement
évidemment que ba et patrice les gens me
disent tous mes comptes plutôt que tout
le monde et les antes mais au courage ou
moments difficiles mais en fait non plus
par mails et revenant l'ordre en fait
c'est qu'on attendait depuis depuis des
années on y était prêt depuis des années
ils dénonçaient comme les push de
vincent lambert un acharnement
thérapeutique pour le maintenir en vie
alors que les parents viviane et pierre
lambert eux estimaient que leur fait
c'était simplement handicapés ils
veulent porter plainte pour meurtre
d'ailleurs dans un communiqué ils
écrivent l'heure est au deuil est au
recueillement il est aussi à la
méditation de ce crime d'état
j'ai décidé qu'une autopsie du corps de
vincent lambert aurait lieu la justice
française a ouvert une enquête pas pour
meurtre mais pour identifier les causes
de la mort l'anc est en recherche des
causes de la mort est à la fois la plus
neutre qui existe dans notre arsenal
procédurales pénale est celle qui permet
de procéder aux investigations utiles
autrement dit à ton respecter la loi qui
permet oui un arrêt des traitements mais
seulement en cas d'obstination
déraisonnable
ce feuilleton judiciaire se poursuit un
bras de fer long et douloureux ici
sébastien desrosiers radio canada
morrell